чи знаєте ви наскільки небезпечний
азбест це токсичне волокно широко
використовувалося у 70-х-80-х роках
багато будівель таких як цю школу позаду
мене більше не можна використовувати
оскільки окрім інших проблем Вони повні
азбесту сам матеріал високотоксичний
нині азбест є причиною половини усіх
ракових захворювань
німець вольфганкляйнер вейгант захворів
саме на такий вид раку у
1970--80-х роках він працював Муля різав
азбестові листи Він захворів на азбестоз
хворобу спричинену впливом асбесту яка
десятиліттями пізніше переросла в рак
легень коли Чуєш діагноз рак легень ти
просто шокований і навіть не питаєш чому
першу підказку Ми отримали в лікарні
вони запитали чи контактував я з
продуктами що містять азбест ось тоді до
мене дійшло так близько 70 країн світу
заборонили чи обмежили використання
азбесту включно з Німеччиною в Україні
використовувати азбест в будівництві
заборонили лише у 2022 році під тиском
ЄС але в інших країнах світу наприклад в
Індії його продовжують використовувати
попри летальні наслідки якщо його не
можна безпечно використовувати в цих 70
країнах тоді його не можна безпечно
використовувати і тут в Індії але що
таке азбест і наскільки Він небезпечний
де люди найбільше піддаються впливу і як
можна припинити його використання в
майбутньому азбест - це природний
мінерал який видобувають із шахт його
волокниста природа та стійкість до тепла
електрики і корозії зробили його цінним
для багатьох етапів будівництва таких як
ізоляція стелі підлоги та
покрівлі використання азбесту стрімко
зросло після Другої світової війни
особливо в Європі А так також в країнах
Азії та Близького Сходу зі збільшенням
використання азбесту зростала і
кількість захворювань аж до
сьогодні дослідження показують що
захворювання пов'язані з азбестом
спричиняють приблизно 255 000 смертей на
рік у всьому світі азбест викликає
хронічне виснажливе захворювання він
викликає мезотеліому азбестоз рак
легенів небезпека асбесту полягає в тому
що в більшості випадків він не викликає
захворювання одразу волокна можуть
перебувати в легенях десятиліттями а
хвороба може проявитися на десятиліття
пізніше як і у випадку з вольфгангом
йому діагностували рак легень у 40 років
через багато років після того як він
працював з
[музика]
азбестом звичайно спочатку цього не
помічаєш просто кашляєш є трохи
мокротиння тоді я ще палив але навіть
тоді ти думаєш що кашляєш від того що
палиш нема має негативних думок Іраку ти
не помічаєш Зазвичай це стає помітним
лише тоді коли стає занадто пізно багато
інших людей страждають так само і часто
це погано закінчується у Німеччині
щороку від захворювань пов'язаних з
азбестом помирає приблизно 13 людей ця
цифра може бути більшою оскільки
багатьох хворих не визнають хворими саме
на азбестоз отримати точні дані про те
скільки людей захворіло або померло на
глобальному рівні ще складніше адже
багато країн не збирають цих даних однак
за оцінками 50 000 людей в Індії щороку
знаходяться під загрозою смерті Ось чому
так багато країн почали обмежувати або
забороняти використання азбесту з кінця
70-х років але є серйозні
винятки яс заборонив асбест у 1990х
роках і ми бачимо що з того часу його
використання значно
скоротилося однак в країнах Азії та
Близького Сходу його використання
продовжується згідно з даними воос у
всьому світі асбест все ще
використовують у понад 30 країнах де
недостатньо засобів контролю та
неврегульоване
законодавство ці матеріали висуваються
Як Швидка дешева альтернатива яку можна
легко використовувати але знаєте часто
про довгострокові наслідки забувають
деякі країни все ще активно займаються
виробництвом або використанням азбесту
попри всі ризики які приносить цей
канцероген Китай Бразилія та Казахстан
були одними з найбільших виробників
асбесту разом видобуваючи близько 550 я
метричних тон проте країною яка
перевищила їх усіх у 2022 році стала
Росія
РФ експортувала а на суму понад 180 млні
доларів США дуже прибутковий бізнес для
країни без Росії світова торгівля
азбестом не процвітала б так як це
відбувається сьогодні там навіть є місто
під назвою азбест де видобувають волокно
його також називають містом що вмирає
через напрочут високу кількість випадків
захворювання на
рак деякі видобувні країни
використовують азбест самостійно інші
експортують його по вому
світу серед найбільших споживачів
азбесто є Росія Індонезія та Китай із
загальним обсягом понад 400 я метричних
тон у 2021 році але Індія перевершує
будь-яку іншу країну за використанням
азбесту ви не можете уявити жодного
місця де б не було асбесту Він в
будівлях трубах водопостачання
транспортних засобах у їхніх гальмівних
колодках і гальмівних кладках у відсіках
для баків немає місця де б не було
асбесту протягом останніх десятиліть
Індія потроху закривала власні шахти але
потім почала імпортувати Матеріал у
величезних кількостях країна
використовує азбест В основному в
будівельному секторі майже не
дотримуючись правил охорони
здоров'я Біологія людини всюди однакова
якщо в Європі азбест отруйний то і в нас
він отруйний якщо його не можна безпечно
використовувати в цих 70 країнах то його
не можна безпечно використовувати і тут
в Індії це бомба уповільненої дії
дослідники побоюються що Протягом
наступних кількох десятиліть понад 6
мільйонів індійців захворіють на
захворювання пов'язані з асбестом у тому
числі понад 600 000 на
рак і найгірше те що багато індійців не
усвідомлюють що вони можуть бути
наступними це моральнибо усіх людей які
розуміють його небезпеку діяти
негайно вос наполягає на негайному
припинені використання
азбесту краще припинити використання
зараз а потім давати Раду з наслідками
успадкованими 50-60 років тому але якщо
країна продовжує використовувати азбест
це лише посилює
проблему
ООН робила кілька спроб заборонити
азбест але їх блокували ряд країн
включно з Росією та індією але одна
країна яка була активно залучена в
торгівлю азбестом тепер зробила поворот
Бразилія заборонила видобуток азбесту у
2022 році після того як верховний суд
уже припинив його використання всередині
країни чи може це стати поворотним
моментом в історії азбесту регіональні
експерти не впевнені ця повна заборона
далека від реальності у липні 2023 року
бразильська асоціація людей які зазнали
впливу від азбесту заявила що попри
заборону азбест продовжують
комерціалізувати та використовувати в
Бразилії це може мати наслідки на
десятиліття вперед як ми бачимо у Європі
тим часом у Німеччині через 30 років
після заборони захворювання пов'язані з
азбестом продовжують
зростати гу пощастило він поборов рак
сьогодні йому майже 70 але він ніколи не
забуде день коли почув свій
діагноз того дня до мене випадково
завітала донька і я повідомив їй сумну
новину я сказав Мелані У мене є 50%
шансів це було брехнею бо у мене було
лише 10% але я тримався за
них
[музика]
Oh